- À Port-aux-basques,
c'est la désolation, des débris
partout. Des objets de la vie
quotidienne projetés très loin
des maisons. Et à travers
ces débris, des résidents,
comme Peter, à la chchchche
de souvenirs.
Des objets à l'effigie
du Canadien, des photos
de sa famille, et sa maison
complètement dévastée.
Il ne reste plus rien de
son paradis juché sur les caps.
"Sa femme ne veut plus habiter
sur le bord de l'océan, dit-il,
ni même la voisine."
Plusieurs résidents craignent
maintenant la mer.
Il leur faudra le l'aide
pour traverser cette épreuve.
Et l'aide, elle arrive.
Un camionneur de St-Jean
a profité d'un transportdededed-
Basque pour ravitailler
les sinistrés.
Chaque voiture a été remplie
de vêtements, de bouteilles
d'eau et de nourriture,
et cela en moins de 24 heures.
"Nous sommes des Terre-Neuviens,
dit-il, c'est ce que les Terre-
Neuviens font."Hélene habite Po.
Elle s'est fait un devoir
de venir prêter main-forte
aux sinistrés.
"J'étais à la maison me
demandant quoi faire pour aider,
alors j'ai dit oui
tout de suite."
Le premier ministre de la
province est venu constater
les dégâts dans la municipalité
ou plus de 80 maisons ont été
détruites.
En découvrant une photo
d'un mariage auquel le ministre
de l'industrie a assisté, Andrew
Parson est rempli d'émotion.
- Le gouvernement promet d'être
présent, même la reconstruction
peut prendre des années.
"Bien des maisons ne sont pas
assurées, et celles qui le sont
ne le sont peut-être pas
lors d'un événement de la sorte,
explique Andrew Furey.
Le gouvernement àààà pour eux
et j'ai confiance que le fédéral
suivra."
Une centaine de soldats
sont arrivés à Terre-Neuve-et-
Labrador.
"Des troupes sont en attente
épépépéploiement. Elles devraiet
être sur le terrain dès que
ce sera possible", explique
l'officier de l'armée.
En attendant, Peter doit rebâtir
sa confiance en la mer,
comme beaucoup de résidents qui
craignent qu'elle ne se déchaîne
à nouveau.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau,
Radio-Canada, Port-aux-Basques